56.3
of white women under the age of 29 that
are liberal have mental
diagnosed mental disorders by medical
health professionals
now the author of this article goes on
to say
they have goals yet who knows how
hampered their day-to-day lives are by
the conditions
they've been diagnosed with well let's
dive into that rabbit hole for a moment
shall we
yes rich let's do it there is a
um page on
uh twitter and it's called
libs of tiktok here it is
all right so uh see we got here
this okay this is an older lady so let's
skip over the older ones here's one
here's a perfect example it's a quick 14
second clip so
hi there you can either respect my trans
homies or i can identify
as a [ __ ] problem and if i catch your
[ __ ] as being disrespectful
your pronouns are going to be was were
thank you for coming and have a nice day
hi there
you can either that's just one example
here's another one
i often so as a fat person
i often dread medical appointments
because of blatant medical fat phobia um
the last ob appointment i went to uh
the provider blended everything on my
weight and told me that i needed to go
on medication that made me feel really
terrible
this ob appointment that i just went to
i've been dreading
and the provider was amazing she asked
me what my pronouns are
she asked me about my name she made me
feel super comfortable
asking about my trauma history so that
she knew how to touch me in ways that
were not harmful she just was like
great um and
i was crying before getting my blood
drawn because
i just never have good experiences with
medical medical providers and so
i just wanted to share like some
experience you guys can go and take a
look at the um
oh here's another one i'm so [ __ ]
tired of this selfish
idiotic behavior i have one
two i have three [ __ ] inhalers
okay it's a little too much swearing on
some of these but
i don't know like does does that look
like mental illness to you
i'm not a medical professional but i'm
guessing on a balance of probabilities
if you take a look at through some of
these
you're probably going to start drawing
similar conclusions
you